hello, go ahead
here this way
it kills me argentina how do you
normally travel to school
I have a double shift so in the morning by
car because I've been to school and in
the afternoon by bicycle to be able to regulate
when your trip lasts fourth door
in the morning approximately 15 minutes and in
the afternoon  5 can your way of thinking
to enter every day of the body
and schedule the bell has already rung but when
the room entered today we are going to do great
things or to achieve something that you like about the
area where it is located neglect my
school it is located on a property
open full of trees so I
love it because the kids learn
freely
who is your favorite movie star
I have my national and
international stars national leo sbaraglia
and international kevin costner
and your favorite singer or band and the
same national charly garcía
and international alejandrosanz  that I
share it with my daughters and I had my grandfather
when you are the only place you
would like to visit  I keep an eye on
Greece
when I had my favorite subject
my favorite material practical activities
and the least now chemistry
definitely chemistry
what kind of active student
committed a little rebellious but
always respectful in the
school cafeteria favorite food
the fruit salad
here  Now the vehicle usually leaves in the
morning on a quarter and in the afternoon I have
different schedules and when you arrive
continue working
by walking
and what are your passions of your
hobbies outside of teaching I am an
architect so architecture can
create invent build houses
transform an abandoned house into
a wonderful work is my passion my
other great passion
what is my proudest achievement as a
teacher
meeting former students and
remembering everything they did with me
we bring you a blackboard to write a
favorite motivating quote it
would be good there are many but I prefer
one from paulo  freire who says
education does not change and  he world changes
the people who are going to change the world
what would be the most important advice you
would give to your students
that they pursue their dreams that they study for that
they prepare themselves do not be afraid of
not knowing ask and that above
all things seek to be  happy end of
May because you became a teacher
I was invited and I loved it